[Music]
from ancient Greece to the 20th century
Aristotle Sigmund Freud and numerous
other scholars were all looking for the
same thing
eel testicles freshwater eels or
Anguilla and Willow could be found in
rivers across Europe but no one had ever
seen the mate and despite countless
dissections no researcher could find eel
eggs or identify their reproductive
organs devoid of data naturalist
proposed various eel origin stories
Aristotle suggested that eels
spontaneously emerged from mud cleaning
the elder argued eels rub themselves
against rocks and the subsequent
scrapings came to life
eels were said to hatch on rooftops
manifests from the gills of other fish
and even emerge from the bodies of
beetles but the true story of eel
reproduction is even more difficult to
imagine and to solve this slippery
mystery scholars would have to rethink
centuries of research today we know the
freshwater eel life cycle has five
distinct stages larval lepto sefa lie
minuscule glass fields adolescent elders
older yellow heels and adult silver
heels given the radical physical
differences between these phases you'd
be forgiven for assuming these are
different animals in fact that's exactly
what European Naturalist thought
researchers were aware of lepto cephalic
and glass eels but no one guessed they
were related to the elvers and yellow
eels living hundreds of kilometers
upstream confusing matters more eels
don't develop sex organs until late in
life
and the entirety of their time in the
rivers of Europe is essentially ye'll
adolescence so when do you reproduce and
where do they do it despite its name the
life of a freshwater eel actually begins
in the salty waters of the Bermuda
Triangle at the height of the annual
cyclone season thousands of 3 millimeter
eel larvae drift out of the Sargasso Sea
from here they follow migration paths to
North America and Europe continents that
were much closer when eels established
these routes 40 million years ago over
the next 300 days Anguilla Anguilla la
vie ride the ocean currents six thousand
five hundred kilometers to the coast of
Europe making one of the longest known
marine migrations by the time they
arrived they've grown approximately 45
millimeters and transformed into
semi-transparent glass eels it's not
just their appearance that's changed if
most marine fish entered brackish
coastal waters their cells would swell
with fresh water in a lethal explosion
but when glass eels reached the coast
their kidneys shift to retain more salt
and maintain their blood salinity levels
swarms of these newly freshwater fish
migrate up streams and rivers
sometimes piling on top of each other to
clear obstacles and predators
those that make it upstream develop into
opaque Elvis having finally arrived in
their hunting grounds Elvis begin to eat
everything they can fit into their
mouths
these omnivores grow in proportion to
their diets and over the next decade
they develop into larger yellow eels in
this stage they grow to be roughly 80
centimeters and finally developed sexual
organs but the last phase of eel life
and the secret of their reproduction
remains mysterious in 1896 researchers
identified lepto Cephalon as larval eels
and deduced that they had come to Europe
from somewhere in the Atlantic however
to find this mysterious breeding ground
someone would have to perform an
unthinkable survey of the ocean for La
Vie no larger than 30 millimeters
enter your Hannah Schmidt for the next
18 years this Danish oceanographer
trolled the coasts of four continents
hunting down increasingly tiny lepto
Cephalon finally in 1921 he found the
smallest larvae yet and the southern
edge of the Sargasso Sea despite
knowledge of their round-trip migration
scientists still haven't observed mating
in the wild or found a single eel
leading theories suggested eels
reproduce in a flurry of external
fertilization in which clouds of sperm
fertilize free-floating
eggs but the powerful currents of
tangling seaweed of the Sargasso Sea
have made this theory difficult to
confirm researchers don't even know
where to look since they've yet to
successfully track an eel over the
course of its return migration until
these challenges
we met the eels ancient secret will
continue to slip through our fingers
from ducks to bedbugs black widow
spiders and bulls there is a shocking
variety of genitalia in the animal
kingdom find out more about the
evolution of nature's nether regions in
this video
[Music]